okay good morning uh we are doing
Mesopotamia today this is the Bron age
uh we did Egypt last class we are doing
Mesopotamia today in the next class we
will finish with the indis valley okay
so uh before I begin um I want to make
three General points about the study of
history and how civilizations develop
okay the first point is
this every culture has a mythology
ology and mythology is the collective
worldview of the
people that lets them understand the
reality around them okay so another idea
that we can say is mythology is a
sheared
reality and every
civilization has mythology so for
example today our mythology would be
Science and History right we think there
are two an objective but they're
actually mythologies they're a sheared
reality and every civilization would
have its own mythology and that's what
makes makes the culture unique okay so
that's the first point so what we will
do today to better understand mesop
botania is to compare contrast its
mythology with that of the Egyptians
okay second point
is um there's an idea called the
dialectic and this was an idea proposed
by the German philosopher named
Frederick Hegel in the 19th century he
believes that history is driven by
opposing
ideas so whenever you have one mythology
or one idea there always must arise
another opposing idea that challenges it
and that's what drives history and
history is always moving towards a
synthesis of
ideas okay so the example would be
there's capitalism and the opposing idea
would be communism the synthesis of the
idea would be
socialism and what's really important to
understand is that ideas can be living
things that change over
time
okay the third idea I want to introduce
is the idea of
diversity and
differentiation and the idea here
is we humans have some fundamental
Natures about us so for example we're
all religious in some aspect
another
fundamental um Instinct about us we
strive to be different and that's why
diversity is the iron law of
society okay so the example is in a
family all the siblings will be
different in a classroom the students
will be
different and you could be a student way
in a
classroom and then you go to another
classroom you and you figure out the
students there are similar to you so you
will change as a person to differentiate
yourself from other
people okay so that's also another
principle of History societies strive to
be different from each other they strive
for diversity and
differentiation we cannot make
generalizations about societies the the
only thing that we can say
is Societies or cultures fall into a
spectrum okay and they're usually
defined by the by the
elite or generalizations okay so this is
another way of saying today I'm I'm
going to make very broad
generalizations about these societies
and
civilizations
and um they're useful for our purposes
but I want I want you to be aware that
these are simplifications these are
generalizations okay all right so let's
start okay so uh
Mesopotamia is a very different culture
and civilization than Egypt because of
its
Geography okay so if you look at the
geography of
Egypt it has natural boundaries so for
example
to the um West is a Sahara Desert to the
north is the Mediterranean
Sea um to the east is the uh Red Sea
okay and then to the South um are the
cataracts so it makes it hard to travel
up the Nile from the south okay so there
are really only two access points into
Egypt which can be easily defended the
South and also from the lavant okay
which is basically Israel Syria
Jordan and because of its natural
boundaries Egypt doesn't really feel
threatened by external enemies
right also it has the now river which is
the foundation of its civilization
remember last class we talked about how
the now uh um was very generous it
flooded predictably every season and so
it made
agriculture very productive in Egypt
which allowed them to sustain a very
large
population which then can be used to
create monuments like the
pyramid okay so for most of its history
Egypt was stable and
prosperous Mesopotamia is completely
different okay so first of all
Mesopotamia which is in what we call um
Iraq today it has no natural boundaries
Mesopotamia uh is Greek for the land
between two rivers these two rivers are
the
Euphrates and the Tigers okay Euphrates
Tigers to
the um west of mesia would be Arabia and
the the lavant okay to the north would
be
Anatolia
to um the east of the Zago
mountains the thing about Anatolia is it
itself is a very prosperous place so it
will become
eventually um home to certain Empires
like the high ties who will always
threaten Mesopotamia okay so Anatolia is
a threat to
Mesopotamia the people of Arabia and the
zaros mountains are nomads and as we
know Nomads are a very aggressive people
and so they will constantly launch raids
against Mesopotamia which threatens its
safety okay
so
Mesopotamia throughout its
history has always been at war with its
neighbors the other thing about
Mesopotamia
is even though it's fertile it's part of
something called a fertile crescent okay
which extends from Mesopotamia into the
lavant okay it's called the
Cresent the euph frees and tigers don't
really
cooperate um they're very chaotic they
change course all the time and so uh the
only way to tame this euph fres and the
Tigers is through
irrigation okay because if you farm too
close to the bed the River Bank you're
going to get flooded okay so they had to
develop Irrigation in order to tame the
fredes and the
Tigers
okay so the geography of these two
cultures are very different and
therefore the history is very different
for most of its history Egypt was
unified as an Empire it was very stable
but
Mesopotamia H was always in flux okay so
the first great civilization of the
Mesopotamia were the samarians they were
eventually conquered by the acadians and
then you have the Assyrians and the
Babylonians and these four civilizations
are what we call Mesopotamia
okay okay any questions so far before I
go into the brief history of Mesopotamia
okay yeah that's a good question okay
but what is the relationship between
these four relationships the samarians
the
acadians uh the the Babylonians and the
Assyrians okay so the very first
civilization were the
samarians and then they were eventually
United by the
acadians okay so Samaria was not really
an Empire it was a culture and a
civilization that was divided into city
states like the Greeks okay before the
conquest of the Macedonian
and the acadians under Saron of aad or
Saron the great
United um the city states and gave us
the idea of um saman
civilization after the kinian empire
fell North Mesopotamia became the
Assyrian Empire South Mesopotamia became
the Babylonian Empire they all saw
themselves as hearers to the Samarian
civilization so even though they're
different civilizations they share a
common mythology okay which I will
discuss later in the
class okay does that make sense great
okay so I'm gonna talk very
briefly about how Mesopotamia develop
okay so remember that in the beginning
agriculture first appeared in two places
Anatolia and the V
okay then there was something called the
8.2 kiloyear
event and we can see this as dramatic
climate
change that radically changed the
geography and the
climate of this
world okay and because of the cooling in
temperature the people in the lavant and
the people in and Anatolia were forced
to spread out so went to they went to
Europe they went to Egypt they went to
Mesopotamia and when they did that they
spread
Agriculture and remember the agriculture
the mythology is the mother goddess
which meant that they were mainly
peaceful eitan people
okay who were very artistic so this is a
very peaceful
stable
world but then you have the
5.9 kiloyear event okay so this is this
is about 6,000 years ago 4,000 BCE and
again you saw a radical
change in
temperature
which again forc migration and forc
um the civilizations to change okay one
of the major
changes
in Mesopotamia is the founding of a
place
called
um iic okay iic and iic is interesting
sorry it's here iic is interesting
because it is considered the first city
of the world and so this is the
beginning of what we call civilization
okay the modern idea of
civilization and has about
40,000 uh
people and this is what we considered
the beginning of the samian
civilization and the saman civilization
is considered the cradle of civilization
it is the beginning of the foundations
of modern civilization they gave us
irrigation technology they gave us
mathematics they gave us astronomy they
gave us writing okay Kun form writing
they gave us the legal system okay they
gave us hierarchy and
religion so there was an explosion of
innovation uh with the founding of
Eric now Eric eventually would become a
huge city which compelled the people to
migrate and found cities that are
similar to ER okay they're basically
colonies and they're and they're
scattered throughout Mesopotamia okay
these are city
states that at first were part of the
earth civilization but eventually they
became um prosperous
and Wealthy uh themselves and so they
broke away from U and this led to
tension and conflict and maybe sometimes
even outright right Warfare but please
remember like during this time the idea
of like massive Warfare that we would
see during the Greek and Roman periods
it's still pretty absent there's
conflict it's short term and they're and
they're and they have conflicts in order
to reserve to to resolve like
territorial disputes okay or trade
disputes but they're not trying to wipe
each other
out
okay um one of the great
Mysteries is where the Samaran come from
we have this problem because when we
discovered kuna form and we translated
the saman language we discovered the
spoken language is very different from
the surrounding regions who spoke
something called a semetic language okay
so the language spoken in the area are
part of a semetic language group but
Sumerian is not part of that group
there's not enough
similarities
also there there is no other language
like Samaran in the world okay it's what
is called a language
isolate it is
unique and so this has puzzled Scholars
for decades and quite honestly no one
knows why this is the case okay no one
knows there are different
theories one theory is the the saman
People Are People Who Came From Anatolia
and
settled uh in the Euphrates because it
was good for agriculture okay so that's
one Theory but there are other theories
there are other people who
believe uh the Samaritans came from the
zos mountains okay there are other
people who believe they came from Arabia
and settled and then there's another
group of people who
believe the Samaran I an are people who
came from the indis
valley okay we'll talk about the indis
valley next class but all you need to
know is the in this Valley it is a very
advanc civilization it's very large 5
million people and it covers three major
areas Afghanistan Pakistan and Northwest
India it is larger than Egypt and
Mesopotamia
combined okay so people believe that the
IND this Valley
sent a colony to Mesopotamia which found
at uich and it makes sense because it's
actually pretty easy to get from in this
Valley to yor because of the Arabian Sea
okay so these are the different theories
but then there's another theory okay
which I think makes the most sense which
is
this Samaran is a creole
language it was
invented by a Melting Pot of cultures
and languages and and it's very similar
to the menu we speak today right where
menu didn't didn't exists but because
you had so many different cultures
coming
to uh the palace they had to create
their own language in order to
communicate with each other we call that
language today Mandu okay does that make
sense okay
so why do I think this idea makes the
most sense and again uh just to be
absolutely clear no one knows and we'll
probably never know the answer but I
believe the cre that Samaran is a Creo
language this Theory makes the most
sense because of
this why was Europe able to develop into
the first city what makes it special the
answer is this it is at the center of
the world
okay so let me
explain from Yu you're able to access
the indis valley you're able to access
the Arian desert you're able to go North
to Anatolia and the zagas mountains okay
and these civilizations we know traded
with each
other because it's the Bronze Age right
because to make bronze you need to to
create an alloy between tin and copper
but also what's important to understand
is we humans have been training with
with each other since the beginning
because we like to explore and we like
to experience different
cultures okay so that's what explains
why U has was able to prosper so fast
because it's a center of the world to
get anywhere you have to go for your
Eric
okay but if that's the case if it's a
trading center of the world it makes
sense for it to be also a
multicultural and
multilingual community of people right
because these Traders from Arabia
Anatolia the zos mountains Also let's
not forget about the Yia okay who are up
here in the steps they also trade with
these people people from the IND Valley
it makes sense for them to come together
in a training
community and develop their own language
their own culture which
spreads also because this is a Melting
Pot it's really in immigrant uh culture
they're able to bring the most advanced
ideas from all around the world and
combine them together which creates new
inventions like writing like legal
system like mathematics like
astronomy okay and that's why saman beca
Samaran became the crit of civilization
because of the meeting place
of the world's cultures and
ideas and because of the very inst
instability of the environment okay
meaning they have to tame the Tigers new
fres um and because they were always
threatened by outside enemies they had
to develop a new culture and new
mythology based on
struggle right
the Egyptians can afford to be passive
and fatalistic let the gods
decide but because this is an immigrant
Community they have to focus on struggle
and achievement which is very much like
America today okay does that make sense
so again this is my theory of the
Samaran people where they came from and
why they are what why they are who they
are okay any question so far before I
continue all right so next next what I
want to do is I want to compare Egyptian
mythology with mesan mythology to show
how the
geographic and cultural difference
translates into the mythology the shared
reality of the people okay so let's uh
look at Egypt first
all right so again Egypt is a very
ancient
civilization and their mythology is
extremely complex they have different
versions of the same stories okay but
I'm going to give you the generalization
which will be useful for our purposes
okay so let's look at
Egypt so and then we'll look at
Mesopotamia
okay Egypt Egypt believed the first God
was raah okay there are there are other
gods who who they believe to the first
God like atum and Aman okay but let's
just say the first God is Rah who is a
son
God he comes to our world and he creates
life okay he basically gives life to
everything okay including
humans and
as such we worship
him but eventually we start to become
misguided and we start to worship
another God a false god Ra becomes angry
and kills many of us and but after he
kills many of us he has tremendous
regret and he decides his time is up he
should give his grown to someone else
okay this other God becomes
Osiris asir Asus is a great God because
he gives people civilization which
includes cities which includes the
pyramids which includes writing okay so
it's isiris who gives us
Civilization now here's a brother named
set and Seth is very jealous of the fact
that Osiris is worshiped by the people
so he plots to usurp the throne from
Osiris so what he does is this he builds
a sarcophagus a tomb okay he presents
presents to Osiris and says Osiris my
great king this
sarcophagus is the most beautiful and
comtable sarcophagus in the world you
will love lying in here and Osiris is
like oh that's interesting let me try so
Osiris like gets into the sarus and set
closes it forever okay then he kills
Osiris and dismembers his body Osiris
has a wife Isis and when he hears upon
he hears about the death of her
husband
she looks for his body and and assembles
it
together H but she can't find the head
and then Osiris becomes the god of the
underworld okay after Osiris is
reassembled he impregnants Isis they a
SE they have a son named
Horus Horus eventually grows up and he's
angered by the fact that his uncle Seth
has usurped his throne okay so the two
are going to
battle and the gods who judge all tell
them they have to challenge each other
to a duel okay so they have a series of
duel one duel is they both turn into
hippopotamus and they try to to um stay
in the river for the longest time
possible Horus seizes as an opportunity
to kill set he tells his mother Isis
while set is
distracted while he's a hippopotamus
take a spear and kill him and Isis
agrees but when she tries to kill s she
is paralyzed with fear and she fails
Horus and anger strikes beheads
uh her mother her mother she he she does
he doesn't kill her but she loses her
head that's how angry is okay so Isis
and Horus continue their challenge
eventually set decides to poison Horus
but before he can do so Horus first
poisons him okay then the Horus becomes
king and he gives Egypt the institution
of kingship so every Pharaoh is a direct
descendant of Horus or another
Reincarnation of Horus okay that is the
Egyptian myth of
creation Now the Mesopotamians okay they
have a
different myth of creation called the
enuma elesh from up high okay the enuma
elesh and this is the story of the enma
ales there are two Gods the first God is
Tiamat Tiamat who is who is basically
salt water okay then you have absu who
is fresh
water the two great Gods get together
they give birth to other gods okay their
children these Gods then give birth to
other gods
okay eventually absu gets annoyed with
his children because children are loud
and he can't see
so he resolves to kill all his children
and bring peace to the
world Tiamat finds out about abu's
diabolical plan he warns she warns her
children the gods get together and they
kill
absu Tiamat is enraged by the death of
her consort and she resolves to raise a
great Army and Destroy her children okay
the Gods get together and they deci they
elect
mardock who is the son of the god so
he's he's basically a third generation
God okay they elect mardar to lead them
in battle against Tiamat okay so you
have these two massive armies converging
against each other and then Tiamat turns
into a huge water Serpent and challenges
mardar to a duel they fight okay mardock
unleashes whirlwinds into the mouth of
uh Tiamat and that sort of like dizzies
her and then Maro strikes her down after
he kills her she uses her body to create
the world she uses half of her body to
create the sky and she uses another half
of the body to create the continents
okay he creates the moons and he creates
the star STS he creates the entire
universe basically from the body of
Tiamat
after
that the gods all decide to rest in
peace but they need people to take care
of them they need people to watch the
land to farm and till the land so they
create humans as their slaves okay
humans
and that's how theem Alish ends okay
each city has its own God and the humans
in that City must Revere and take care
of that God to be their slave for all
eternity
okay all right so as you can see right
away there are massive differences
between Egyptian mythology and
Mesopotamia
mythology okay the first major
difference
is um the gods are benevolent right the
gods give us everything we just sit back
the gods will give us life they will
give us civilization they will give us
kingship they will give us a
pyramids so all all we have to do is
respect and Revere and worship the gods
we humans don't need to participate in
the order of things
but in the Le we find out that
gods are extremely
violent and they demand our
servitude they're our masters okay so we
must constantly work to
please the um
Gods that's one major difference second
major difference is as you can see uh
from The Egan mythology
the main
virtue that
wins out is cleverness okay deception
trickery and you can say this is because
For the Longest Time Egypt was an Empire
So What mattered was not the ability to
go to war but the ability to to
manipulate um Eternal politics okay what
we call Palace
Intrigue and this is no different from
China right because remember in China we
have something called uh shuna The Art
of War by Sha that is a manual on Palace
intrig right how to trick other people
it's not a manual on how to go to
war
okay but
here the
value that
is most most prominent in Mesopotamia is
bravery or strength okay not cleverness
there's no trickery going on it's just
pure power pure
bravery
okay and the third major difference is
in Egypt they believe the gods are
helping each other okay they build on
top of each other's
legacies that's what progress is that's
what Improvement is but in mesia they
believe in something call Creative
destruction which is to say in order to
create something new you must destroy
the
old okay tat represents the old
therefore she must be destroyed and from
the old you can build a new civilization
but you must
first destroy the old
and conflict is a source of
creativity okay does that make
sense and again they have these two
different mythologies because they're
reflecting the shared reality of the
different geographies and
history
okay okay any questions so far before I
continue
are you clear okay right great okay all
right let's continue all
right okay
so both Egypt and both mopia they are in
a
struggle to prove NE mythologies are the
best Okay the reason why is remember
that this is a time when all these
civilizations are trading with each
other but but also what's important to
understand is there's a lot of migration
going
on and people have a choice if you're
not happy here you can always uh move
somewhere else okay there isn't any idea
of like Nation or culture or race people
have
autonomy okay so you need to constantly
prove that your civilization is the best
to attract people which provides the
labor to drive your civilization
right so the Egyptians created something
called the pyramids the
pyramids to show the people around them
we are favored by the gods because it's
only the gods who could Inspire us to
build the parids
okay so now the people in M have a
problem because how do you compete
against the pyramids
right I mean at first they tried they
created things called the Z ziggurats
the ziggurats which are temples to house
the
gods okay but then they did something
that was completely different and which
made them Immortal just as the pyramids
made the Egyptians Immortal they create
something called The Epic of gilam mas
and today we celebrate the Epic of gamh
as the first work of world
literature okay so let me first explain
the plot of the Epic of gilgames and
show you um how it reflects Mesopotamian
culture and values and then explain the
meaning of it okay so the EP Mash so
there was a king of Eric okay the first
city
um uh Eric he's and he's the king of the
first city and
he's a demigod
okay he's huge he's a giant and he's
very
brave the problem
is even though he's built this great
City Eric High walls prosperous
land uh Advanced civilization he gets
bored very quickly he starts to bully
the people around him so he sees young
man he challenges challenges them to a
fight and he beats them up okay he's a
bully he also rapes all the young women
in
Eric and this drives their parents to
pray to the gods for Relief so the gods
decide TR to create an equal to gash and
his name is eadu
anadu NAD do is made of
clay the two fight and even though gig
Mash defeats anadu in
battle gigg Mash is happy because he
thinks he's found a good friend someone
is equal who he can share adventures
with so the two become great friends the
best of friends they go on on these
adventures
together and these
Adventures are tremendous challenges for
example they challenge Gods to battle
and at first they're afraid but through
their friendship and through their
bravery they're able to Triumph in the
end there's a god named
ishar and she falls in love with gilam
as because he's so
heroic but gigle Mash rebuffs isar
because gig Mash is basically basically
knows that isar wants to turn him into
her sex slave he doesn't want that he
wants his freedom he wants to prove he's
great
hero isar is feels rejected uh feels
ashamed so she sends something called
The Bull of Heaven to destroy
Earth gash and eadu fight the both
heaven and they kill this great bow the
gods now are really pissed off at g
match anadu and and they decide that
enadu must die so they inflict a disease
on enadu which kills him at this point
gilam as is heartbroken he's lost his
best
friend at the same time he knows death
is waiting for him he has all these
accomplishments he's a great King he's
built this great City but eventually he
must die he does not want to die he
fears death so he hears about this
Immortal man this man who has lived
forever and who will live
forever and he decides to seek him out
on his journey he has to overcome many
hurdles and along the journey along the
journey everyone implores him gig Mas
give up this vant project immortality is
for the god Gods we are humans we must
die that's what makes us different from
the gods enjoy your life
drink be
merry and but G but gilam as refuses to
turn back and he insists on continuing
on his journey eventually he finds this
Immortal man who explains to him he was
made Immortal because he survived the
great flood
the God created humans but the humans
became too
loud for the gods so the gods resolved
to kill
them but this man this one man was
favored by one God so he was told about
this plot and he built a boat and put a
lot of animals in the boat in order to
escape and this is this is the basis of
the uh story of the North flood in the
Bible
okay after the flood receded this man
came down and built an altar to worship
the gods the gods felt regret for what
they did so in compens so so to
compensate they promis never to do this
again to never destroy Humanity again
and also they Grant this man
immortality okay so but this is just a
oneof the gods will never do this again
and so the men tells gig
mash the search for immortality it's
pointless just go home but gig Mash
refuses to give up so the man challenges
gig Mash to not sleep for seven nights
and six days uh sorry six days and seven
uh six nights and seven days Okay g
tries but he can't do it so it's all
futile
and then he goes home but the moment he
goes home he has an epiy he sees the
Great Walls of Eric he sees the people
happy in Eric and he realizes this is
what immortality is immortality is not
living forever
immortality is to be
remembered by the people who love you
so the irony of all this is he goes on
this search for immortality he fails but
because he goes on this search because
he goes on on this Quest he becomes
Immortal because his story his
struggle is remembered and celebrated by
the people in the Epic of gig
Mas okay so this is a reflection of the
values of Mesopotamia the point is in
the achievement the point is not in the
victory the point is in the exploration
the point is in the
struggle and that's why the means were
so Innovative but that's also why they
went to war with each other all the
time
okay and this is the beginning of the
idea of literature
where memories can be shaped in such a
way that become so beautiful that it
becomes
implanted in the minds of others for
centuries which will inspire them to
Greater Heights of achievement okay so
now we have the beginning of literature
and that is the legacy of Mesopotamia
the legacy of the of the Egyptians were
a testament to the tremendous creativity
of humans of Egypt okay the humans in
Egypt but the Epic of giges is also a
testament to the tremendous creativity
of That
civilization and if you think about it
the Epic of gigle Mash was written
because it is in a dialectic with the
pyramids right the Epic of Gil is also
saying to the
pyramids immortality it is an illusion
eventually these pyrs will collapse for
the pharaoh to seek immortality is a
delusion what matters is for the pharoh
to look after the well-being of his
people here and now because that's why
he will be loved and remembered for
eternity he will die if his people die
but if you you people if your people
live on because of your
contributions then you'll be remembered
forever you'll become
immortal right and that's the story of
gash okay any
questions is this all pretty
clear okay all
right so I will make a final point
about these stories okay within these
stories we can see the evolution of
societies over time okay so let's go
back to the story of the anuma
elesh so remember Tiamat in absolute
create the world that's the first story
then um the god are created okay and
they they inhabit the world that's
Second Story and then
Tiamat and mud go to war and then from
the victory of this war M creates the
universe okay so basically we're seeing
three different mythologies ined within
this mythology which gives us the idea
of social change and evolution in mopia
at this time okay so the first story is
Tiamat right who's Tiamat she's the
mother goddess
right she's the one who gives life so
this shows mesopen as an Agricultural
Society then you have the emergence of
the Gods which the urban people would
celebrate okay and then finally you have
the battle between Tiamat and uh mardar
and this shows the battle between the
old Society with the new Society okay
the urban and the agricultural the
agricultural it is
egarian it is peaceful the urban is
patriarchal
right so
why how do we explain or how do you
justify the transition from an equal
Society to a patriarchy the answer is
this the answer is embedded in the
mythology right theat represents
chaos Monarch represents order so even
though we are letting go of the old
we're destroying the old it's to create
a more peaceful and orderly World okay
so remember Tiamat is the water Serpent
and for the longest time we believe the
water serpent the water serpent
represent life and Divinity okay why
because if you think about it the
serpent water serpent looks like the
river and the river is the basis of all
civilization right so and this is true
for most civilizations in China what do
we call the water
serpent what what do we call the water
serpent in
China
long
right the problem
is the river
floods and if you flood too much you
destroy civilization so it's
chaotic
okay and that's why it's important to
have a patriarchy or an urban Elite
because they can you they can help us
command us to create
irrigation to build walls which will
tame the river and the water
serpent okay does that make sense so
within this mythology we are seeing the
evolution of society from an egalitarian
one to a
patriarchy okay
also we are in the EP gash we are
witnessing the transition from a um
Society based on a a great king to one
that is more organized around a biocracy
right
right because remember the story starts
with the King going on all these
Adventures okay the story ends with the
King coming back and
recognizing what matters is the
well-being of his
people and for that you need a
bureaucracy to manage everyday
Affairs
okay and so this this represents uh this
you can interpret this as uh
representing the beginning of a
bureaucratic Elite which will help the
king order the world in a way that
brings more stability and prosperity to
the
people okay but at F but first the king
must recognize his own hubris he must
become humble
okay so the great Fe
of the Mesopotamians is their King will
become like the pharaoh who will Channel
all resources to building this
Monument which will create inequality
corruption and waste in society which
will lead to massive suffering during
times of
drought
okay okay any questions
um yeah so um mesan the irrigation was
very advanc because the tigers and
Euphrates were very incorporative okay
they would change course all the time so
they have to De very very Advanced ARG
systems that would change over time the
thing about um Samar
is because it's trading and because
there different different city states
this is it becomes a hot bed of
innovation because if one city state
creates a really good irrigation system
another city state could just cop it
really easily
okay um does that make
sense um any more questions
okay so next class we'll discuss the
indis valley
civilization okay and the in valley
civilization if we just use the analysis
we did today we're basically geography
is Destiny you would think the in Valley
Civilization is very much like the
Egyptian civilization
where you have a monarchy you have
centralized Authority where they build
these great monuments okay the irony is
uh when you look at the IND valley
civilization and it's a huge huge
civilization they have very advanced
technology they have like these big
cities that are very welld
designed um they have Plumbing they have
sanitation they even have air
conditioning these towers that sort of
like trap hot
air um people live for a very long time
like I think over half of the population
will live past 55 which is incredible
which is incredible achievement um but
what is Starling about the civilization
the IND Val civilization is it's
peaceful and it's
egalitarian so it's complete mystery as
to why they're so different from Egypt
and Mesopotamia okay because again Egypt
it's a centralized Empire Mesopotamia is
always at
War okay so next class we will look at
the in this in this valley civilization
and try to resolve the Paradox as to why
it is
Advanced um prosperous but at the same
time peaceful and and egalitarian okay